nominé pas une mais deux fois en une
semaine
une consécration pour le président
américain qui a reçu la nouvelle avec
humilité j'ai été nommé deux fois pour
le prix nobel de la paix ce n'est pas
rien je ne sais pas j'aurais dû être
nommé sept fois en raison de tout ce que
nous avons fait cette nomination on la
doit notamment au député norvégien
christiane tim kring et deux du parti du
congrès qui salue le rôle du président
américain dans la signature de l'accord
entre israël et les émirats arabes unis
je pense qu'il a fait plus d'efforts
pour instaurer la paix entre les nations
que la plupart des autres nominés au
prix nobel de la paix et avec pas moins
de 48 postes sur twitter et instagram
relayé par le président américain et son
équipe de campagne
la nouvelle a failli passer inaperçu je
ne dis pas ça par ego mais j'ai été
nominée pour le prix nobel de la paix
[Applaudissements]
maintenant je dois vous l'avouer c'est
assez énorme et des réseaux ainsi que la
plupart des médias ne l'ont pas relayer
vous vous rendez compte
quand obama a pris ses fonctions ils ont
dit on va lui donner le prix nobel de la
paix et lui a répondu qu'est ce que j'ai
fait pour ça je n'ai rien fait il n'a
rien fait en huit ans honnêtement à 43
jours de l'élection présidentielle
donald trump surf sur cette nouvelle
image de président de l'apc c'est un
honneur durement gagné bien mérité pour
ce président la politique étrangère du
président trump sera toujours une
politique de paix par la force et c'est
ce que les américains envoient à
l'étranger une politique de paix par la
force une spécificité propre au
président américain qui en fait sans
doute un candidat de choix pour le
célèbre prix norvégien qui récompense la
lutte pour les droits de l'homme et la
liberté
après tout les trolls sont une invention
scandinave